let's have a look at these together I
know a lot of you maybe didn't quite get
there which is fine you learn something
as we have a go ok now I've asked for
just answers only one of the reasons why
it's before we get to a lighting process
you can have a look in you all sure if
you've got this insight you should look
at this and you should take does that
make sense
is it reasonable ok whether it's right
all right another question ok what I was
just doing our are all of these
attributes along with me just draw a
small set of active it doesn't have to
be big or beautiful you're a small can
actually decide where you put this I'm
going to say you don't even necessarily
need to have a rule of this because
you're just looking for a ballpark check
is this like a reasonable plan sorry and
you don't need a ruler to confirm them
so I've got the Cartesian plane over
there negative 1 comma 3 negative 1
which way do I go because I say you want
that it's to the left because the first
number is horizontal so here I am
1 unit to the left I see there's a 3 so
that takes me upwards right second
numbers vertical so we'll go 1 2 3
that's where P ok so put those in the
same way I'm going to go at this guy
look at where he is
so 1 2 3 actually been quite short big
enough that's all right and then down to
negative 5 so 1 2 3 4 5 so here I am
currently that's cute
on exam now this doesn't lead you
through size you can see a fall off maxi
this is just so I can check give me
about right I'm going to join PQ right
that's an interval by the way an
interval has a start and an end a line
goes on forever
there's my interval now when I have a
look at what I think is the answer one
other half have a look with that there's
one or two right so one other heart
should be halfway between those so looks
like something around
yeah does that match up with the art of
it you got looks pretty good right and
even though it's not like bang on well I
did it pretty roughly so all I'm doing
is making sure yet reasonably so good
work if you got one and a half comma
negative one okay now then your focus is
up but I know a few of you got it I'm
curious we could go ahead and do the
same thing we did before but how did you
get to come zero if you did someone else
would suggest how they were that okay
you ten
I should put your pins down and look up
ribbon just because large it delights
gave an excellent on top really about
half Moss has it so I'm going to repeat
it since I got it right okay the first
things I did was he went straight to the
midpoint bullion company remember it I'm
going to put me brackets what comes
first x1 plus XG
you're taking the average of these two
numbers you add a device
what's it exit okay so you're doing the
same thing what's the X is once for the
one thing they have a look here I'm
interested because the larger suggested
that we're going to put things into this
business formula but hold on it so it's
mid point for quorum a second look at
the information that we've got is a so
this is x1 y1
but what x2 y2 like there is this x2
watch it I'm the same people shaking
head but why I mean it's the other set
of wonders why don't I use that as X you
want to do you want to suggest to me why
Helen what do you think so this is what
you're going to get at the end right in
fact the way I write it is like this I
know what the midpoint is I like in
question one way I'll translate it the
midpoint is provided to me right yeah so
now what I can do is I can substitute x1
y1 the reason is that x2 y2 in the
question is because x2 and y2 are the
answer does that make sense that's sure
going to work so I'm just going to put
one line of working clear you can
compare it to yours it's going to
something like this look 0 plus that and
4
so what you've actually produced for
yourself is a pair of equations have a
look at them with me see this plugin
this one it's x1 so what does it
correspond to on the one hand side
what's one equal to its your f of X 2
over 2 v they match right this morning
patient is another one
the - what's that equal to is equal to 4
plus y 2 over 2 like that so that's why
you can see for example if I wrote that
down 2 equals 4 plus and y 2 over 2 do
you see what's going to happen right I
want to solve what will I do what can I
do the most oh I think I'm going to get
rid this guy by multiplying by 2 that
gives me this now one I could subtract 4
from both sides that gives me that and
that which is exactly what the
individual okay you can confirm to get
to the other side okay so a good job if
you got max